what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i am going
to be talking about the question is
there misogyny in the manosphere is the
manosphere sexist before i start don't
forget to subscribe to the channel and
bring that notification bell that way
you're going to be notified of my daily
video i get this question a lot like
from girls and guys do i think the man
of sphere is sexist
um so i'm gonna give you guys the case
for why it is sexist and the case for
why it isn't sexist
um so i'm gonna talk about a couple like
things that i've experienced in the mana
sphere that i would say are pretty
sexist
um and then but don't worry i'm going to
do both sides so i'm going to do like
after i'm going to talk about
why it isn't sexist um okay so the first
reason that the manosphere
is a little bit sexist is because
no matter what you say as a girl people
always assume that my opinions are
because i'm emotional and i don't like
the truth so it doesn't matter if i'm
saying the exact same thing as some of
the other content creators or other
people in the manosphere because i'm a
woman like it's always assumed
that my opinions are there because
um i'm emotional and i don't like the
truth if i disagree with like what the
mainstream man of sphere says
um
yeah and it's you know it is what it is
i think women in general are more
emotional than men so i understand like
why people think the way they think but
it can be a little bit frustrating when
i have stats and logic to like back up
my claims and people still
just assume it's because i'm emotional
and i'm a girl
okay the second piece of i guess
misogyny sexism in the mannosphere
is no matter what you say people just
assume
that you give bad dating advice because
you're a female i'm not even a heavily
into like dating advice at this point
because i really want to like study pick
up study the red pill a little bit more
before i give advice to guys um but it's
a little bit frustrating that i know if
i ever do a dating advice channel or if
i ever start to give men's dating advice
that no matter what i say it's assumed
to be bad because i'm a girl like you
see so many red pill and like
man-o-sphere content creators say never
take dating advice from women um women
are emotional
and i understand why they say that
because a lot of girls do give bad
dating advice but
when you are in the category of a more
logical girl a girl that does look at
facts acknowledges the red pill
acknowledges the manosphere it's a
little bit frustrating
that
it's just assumed that anything you say
is bad because of i'm a female and
that's the definition of sexism is
treating someone a certain way because
they're a girl like i don't i don't care
if people attack my argument or attack
if they don't think what i'm saying is
true but when you constantly are getting
oh she's a girl she can't give good
dating advice oh she's a girl um she's
emotional that's why she thinks the way
she thinks um it's it's a bit
frustrating okay i will say as a girl in
the manosphere you are constantly
constantly judged on your looks so in
the comments section like you i i get so
many comments you're for your average at
best uh which i don't care because like
honestly i don't it doesn't matter if
you guys find me attractive like it only
matters if the guy i'm dating finds me
attractive if my future husband finds me
attractive so it really
doesn't matter like what the audience
thinks but
you know what i mean it's not fun to
constantly be told uh you're a four
like all the time
but
do i lose sleep over it am i crying over
it no not really
um okay as a girl i will say number four
you are judged a little bit more harshly
um i would say this is just anecdotal
i'm not
saying this is set in stone but i would
say you're judged a little bit more
harshly for your relationships and if
you
have a failure in your relationship
because
the way the red pill thinks it's
automatically assumed that it's the
reason that a relationship didn't work
out is hypergamy the reason that
if the relationship ended is because you
broke up with that person um there's no
such thing as a mutual breakup so people
make a lot of assumptions without
knowing the facts or knowing what
happened because of that worldview
so um
i don't know if that's sexist but i
would just say that's like a problem in
the manosphere okay so let me talk about
why i don't think the man of sphere is
sexist um i think as a girl
um
your content gets more views and gets
more attention just because there aren't
a lot of girls in this space so one of
the reasons that i think my channel blew
up faster one is because i would say i'm
a little bit more logical and less
emotional than most girls and on top of
that
i don't know i think people find it
interesting to watch a girl react to
this content so i will say that i think
my channel blew up faster because i'm
female and because i'm a girl i think
that it's a major advantage to me in the
space because there aren't really a lot
of girls doing it
um second reason that i don't think the
manosphere is
sexist is because i've never been turned
down to go on a podcast because i'm a
girl i've never
been turned down for collaboration if
anything i think it's easier for me to
get collaborations than men
um like for example there was a rapper
that
accepted my invitation to collaborate
but turned down someone with more
followers and more clout than me so i
would say that
i would say that being a girl definitely
has has has its advantages in the
manosphere because at the end of the day
like i think society treats you
different and if not better as a girl
okay third reason that i don't think
that manosphere is sexist is
i think if you really listen
the man of sphere gives you good advice
as a girl for example i never thought
about
how badly a lot of men like want to be
appreciated by girls
and i didn't realize how bad it is out
there dating for girls so if you're a
girl and you really listen to what men
are saying
it makes it easier like in your
relationship to be that person for your
partner it makes it easier to become the
person that men want to be with
um
it also makes it easier because when you
understand men's problems you understand
a lot like where they're coming from um
for example like i wasn't really aware
of how often men are used for their
money for their resources so
as a girl i think if you really listen
and understand that problem you can
better come up with a solution
for example like if i was going to give
women's dating advice i would definitely
tell a woman to
not
have a guy spend a ton of money on you
on a first date you don't want him to
feel used if he changes his mind and
like honestly in the beginning you're
just getting to know each other
um yeah so overall do i think the man of
sphere is sexist as a movement no i
don't i think there's sexist parts of it
just like any movement i think that
there are positives and negatives but do
i feel like i'm heavily discriminated
against because i'm a female in the
manosphere no
i don't so let me know in the comments
if you guys agree or you disagree don't
forget to subscribe to the channel bring
that notification bell and i will talk
to you guys next time